actuellement les adolescents ou les
jeunes adultes autistes
lorsqu'ils arrivent à l'âge ne fait 18
ans c'est la cassure parce qu'il n'y a
plus aucune structure ou très peu de
structures pour les prendre en charge
septembre 1986 cette journaliste
pointait du doigt le manque de
structures pour les adultes autistes
un constat qui traverse les décennies en
france si aucunes données
épidémiologiques n'existe à ce jour la
haute autorité de santé estime à 600
mille le nombre d'adultes autistes et
les structures pour les prendres en
charges restent encore rares ou
inappropriés dans les années 90 ce
président d'association s'inquiétait
déjà des conséquences de cette réalité
il est question de quinte ou 5000
autiste qui n'ont pas de solution du
tout absolution ça veut dire quoi qui
sont dans la famille ou ou qui sont
vraiment dans des endroits qui ne leur
convient pas du tout parmi ces endroits
et à l'hôpital psychiatrique pour les
adultes de prise en charge au même titre
que d'autres patients atteints de
schizophrénie ou de paranoïa les
cocktails médicamenteux font parfois
partie du quotidien des personnes
autistes en hôpital psychiatrique
un traitement chimique inadapté à ce
trouble spécifique selon cette
spécialiste
moi j'ai vu des gens se manger les
doigts dans cet hôpital là encore
l'année dernière après une mise sous
neuroleptiques et j'ai enlevé les
neuroleptiques et la personne
actuellement elle est dans un foyer de
vie qui s'est ouvert justement du côté
de nad et cette personne elle en train
de faire pareil c ap parce que c'est pas
le mot mais un métier cuisinier un
placement en hôpital psychiatrique
difficile à vivre aussi pour les parents
de personnes autistes
face à cette dure réalité certains
prennent parfois des décisions
dramatiques
c'était le cas de cette femme en 1996
sophie sa fille avait 23 ans et son
calvaire d'enfants autistes avait
commencé vers l'âge de 2 ans alors ce
matin là madame rousseau lui a fait
prendre du terral haine pour qu'elle
perde connaissance puis celle là est
tout fait pour que jamais plus
dira-t-elle elle ne retourne à l'hôpital
psychiatrique
l'une des rares structures d'accueil
pour adultes
depuis 2004 et malgré les quatre plan
autisme des différents gouvernements
la france a plusieurs fois été condamné
par le conseil de l'europe pour ses
carences en matière de prise en charge
des personnes autistes
certains parents décourager choisissent
de partir en belgique
là bas des dizaines de structures
médico-sociales accueille les adultes
autistes français mickaël et alexandre
ont dû s'exiler à plusieurs centaines de
kilomètres de chez eux dans cette
structure belge avec 23 autres autistes
les parents de frank 36 ans n'ont pas eu
le choix
vous ne trouvez pas de structures en
france tout simplement
avant d'arriver ici et dans un hôpital
psychiatrique d'après l'association
autisme france
au moins 4000 personnes autistes des
adultes et des enfants seraient
aujourd'hui accueillis en belgique
[Musique]